I don't find Islam
convincing and for me a lot of it is uh
how it's rooted in paganism and like how
the pagans of Muhammad's time called him
an ear why because he would very much
take from uh the Gnostic Christians he
would take from the Jews he was the pag
where's your evidence for that okay if
two people are fighting in a UFC and I
say one guy's looking quite beat down
and I say hey I want to put my money on
that guy what's impressive about that
cuz that's what your Propet did and I
don't find anything impressive like so
it's not the knockout that you think it
is say that again they were going back
and forth there was going there was
times when Persians were winning Romans
so what's this impressive prophecy you
will find out in a minute yeah it's very
impressive actually it's actually I
believe this is a knockout blow yeah for
anybody number one let me tell you
something did I did I specify listen to
Theo listen to look you're you're a
Christian don't come and say to me
you're not a Christian you're a
Christian and you are here lying
pretending that oh I'm just coming to
learn you're not you are someone that's
hostile you're hostile you're
misrepresent my your did janaza pray
over you your funeral was happening you
[Music]
buried we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah subhana
tala in the country of Norway click on
the link and donate now for the sake of
Allah subhana tala he wants he sld you
out so he wants to he came to see
you well he not Christian I'm in I'm
inquiring I'm agnostic so I don't want
to misspeak on the faith or misrepresent
it yeah um I was talking to uham yeah
the sh yeah about uh why I don't find
Islam convincing yeah
and for me a lot of it is uh how it's
rooted in paganism and like how the
pagans of Muhammad's time called him an
a why because he would very much take
from uh the Gnostic Christians he would
take from the Jews he would C the pagans
where's your evidence for that so it's
the evidence is within that uh the texts
that outdate the time of Muhammad which
is which is Gnostic Gospels like what
like uh the Gospel of Judas the Gospel
of Thomas that very much
influenced what Muhammad taught so
where's your evidence that that
influenced that but rather is not from
the same source so the evidence of that
is um that uh the the people were very
much present in the region these people
the gnostics the Jews obviously and um
we see that Muhammad was called an ear
because he was um he was called a what
he was called an ear by the
pagans what it meant was that he was um
listening to what he was told and then
he was preaching it like it was his
Revelation ald where where is he
from okay okay okay alhamdulillah really
okay so um yeah so what I was going to
say is the following so you need to
First bring evidence that number two the
Quran in itself wait sorry I gave you
the evidence you you you didn't give me
evidence you made claims you said to me
that these certain what are they called
The Gospel of what Gospel of Judas goel
of Thomas text out and clearly influence
Muhammad okay no problem so where is
your evidence that they influenced him
and number two can you show me the
correlation where for example the Quran
copied from there cuz I can make clear
clear claims that that's not the case so
what's your claim cuz you're claiming
that just because they were before he
copied so tell me something that is
copied from there that the Quran is okay
the evidence is that we see the Gnostic
text uh talk about things like the
crucifixion of Jesus making it uh made
to appear that way and we see that with
Muhammad's
teachings so so okay one second Allah
says that he was not crucified nor was
he killed so this thing of for example
understanding what that means for
example it was a so somebody the
replacement Theory these are all um
people Scholars who have said this could
be the case the Quran doesn't say that
the Quran clearly says he was not
crucified they did not kill him no they
crucify him so the Quran doesn't say he
was replaced or something like that it
doesn't say that so when you talk about
this schol as we know well respected
Scholars
like I would like you to give the
brother yes yeah this will in teach you
how to pray Salah bro step by step if
you have any questions you turn to the
back the QR code the QR code in the QR
code will um you can book instructors
that will teach you how to PR
Salah yeah okay yeah so yeah so um now
the question is for example do you
follow the Bible today sorry do you
follow the Bible of today so for me like
I said I'm inquiring into Christianity I
don't want to um misrepresent it or
misspeak it but generally yes okay so if
you do then for example if the Quran
copied for example we have a clear
example when it comes to an historical
um historical um fact that the Bible got
wrong but the Quran got right so if
that's the case the Quran could never C
from the Bible very simple for example
in the Quran in the Bible when you read
the Bible it talks about the time of
Joseph and it talks about the time of
Moses correct okay okay good in the time
of Moses it refers to the rer as a
pharaoh in the time of Moses it calls
refers to the ruler as a pharaoh good
okay now if the Quran and the prophet
Muhammad copied from the Bible it would
have copied it mistake why they copi the
mistake because when you look into the
Quran the Quran also talks about Joseph
YF and it talks about Moses so now when
we look at those two instances the Quran
makes something very very unique when he
talks about the time of Joseph it refers
to the ruler as a king not as a pharaoh
but when he talks about the Moses's time
it says when Moses went to Pharaoh so
the question is very simple when they
deciphered as you know I don't know if
you know hieroglyphics was a dead
language sorry hieroglyphics in Egypt it
was a dead language okay they deciphered
the hieroglyphics when they found out
the Rosetta Stone the Rosetta Stone
helped them understand the hieroglyphics
when they understood the hieroglyphics
they came to the conclusion that at the
time of Joseph there were no pharaohs so
the Bible calls the ruler of pharaoh
that does not historically follow
because there were no pharaohs the
dynasty of pharaohs was not there
pharaohs deem themselves to be Gods so
the Quran if C the Bible why did it not
copy that mistake so for me how I would
address this looking at the way it was
referred to differentiates no problem
yeah I would say that um within the
cultural context uh there could have
been different ways to refer to them
different words and things like this uh
I all I don't see that as I don't see
that as a problem no no that's that's a
massive problem you saying it's not a
problem does not make her not problem
this is a massive problem it's like me
saying oh today is not cold today is hot
no I'm saying in language there's
different
not at all King and Pharaoh say all King
no no no I'm telling you clearly you
can't say not at all King and Pharaoh
are not the same thing the dnasty
Pharaoh Dynasty is f later and also
Pharaoh deem themselves to be Gods King
does not a king did not ever deem
himself to be a God so what I'm saying
is the Bible makes that this is a
historical mistake there is no Kings at
the time of there's no pharaohs at the
time of Joseph the the Bible is making a
categorical historical Mistake by the
findings that we have today the Quran
gets it right how how did the Quran know
this number one it look it proves two
things number one it proves that the
Quran is from God number two it proves
that the Bible the Quran never copy from
the Bible no so so even if we take that
argument at face value all it all it
demonstrates is that the Quran uh used
the correct title it doesn't say
anything origin it's not even impressive
mean you have many hisorical it's very
impressive no it's very impressive
people were historic it's very
impressive you just don't know what to
say and I hear you here you are just say
just say I've got nothing to say that's
what you're doing cuz right now you're
just basically saying I've got nothing
to say Ali the problem is no you're not
you're you're not being genuine you're
not being I address what you said you're
not being genu you made a giant leave
look you not being genuine you are not
being genuine it's impossible you're
saying you're being just genous like in
front you're going to continue
interrupting me so you're say finish so
you're saying it got a his historical
title right yes okay therefore what
therefore it Prov is from God how how do
you get that LE very very simple let me
tell I make that lead the Quran claims
is from God
in order for it to claim from it has to
bring certain Miracles that we can say
hold on a second no one could know this
but God Almighty for example I give you
one I can give you plenty now it says
that you said Muhammad peace be upon Him
copied from the Christian scripture this
debster and proves the Quran is from God
how firstly the Bible makes a historical
mistake a historical error historical
fallacy which is what at the time of
Joseph there were pharaohs there were no
pharaohs at that time period
historically stumped done if the Bible
says there were pharaohs it is making a
mistake in history number one number two
the Quran doesn't make the same mistake
it's not a coincidence the Quran says
and when Joseph went to the king now the
question I'm asking is why does the
Quran make this unique subtle correction
because if it's copying from the Bible
it would copy the mistake which it
doesn't and we only came to know about
this when they found the res Stone they
decipher the hieroglyphics and say well
hold on a second the Pharaoh Dynasty
doesn't even go that far so which means
that how did the Quran know this
historical uh accuracy how Okay so first
of all I would say that um you're sort
of um and again when I speak on
scripture I don't to miss speak so
you're sort of holding uh the Bible to
the same standard you try and hold your
Quran to which it doesn't me that's it
can't but the Bible um obviously has
multiple um manuscripts over time um
uh um so I don't see a problem with
these things I don't find it to be
entirely infallible it's what it conveys
that matter it doesn't matter if it said
king or Pharaoh so much that's not
that's not a
problem so you going to answer my
question you you didn't answer my
question you just said to me there's
many scriptures Etc it doesn't really
matter to me again it's it's like it's
like me telling you today is cold but
you're like no I feel hot and I'm like
bro it's actually cold and I show you
the the from and I'm like look it's cold
you're like no no today is hot you did
not address my answer you and and and
I'm not doing this to catch you up but
you know very well you have no answer to
it I don't see how I I I didn't answer
it for you okay repeat repeat how did
you I'm ask you a simple question number
one the fact that the Quran didn't copy
that mistake does it show that it
doesn't copy the Bible the fact the
Quran doesn't copy so if the prophet
Muhammad was copying the Bible he would
have
copied nearly everything why when he was
copying this because the story of Joseph
and the story of mos also mentioned in
the Quran why did the prophet Muhammad
say okay I'm going to copy the bible let
me see what the Bible calls the ruler oh
it calls him a pharaoh I Le that in the
Quran but he goes no no no no no I'm
going to call the Pharaoh not a pharaoh
I'm going to call him a king number one
this dis proves that number two how did
the prophet Muhammad know this fact if
it's from himself and he's copying from
these Christians so you could have been
copying from um oral Traditions that
held to this fact or that um but the
fact was Pharaoh there was no Kings how
could he copy something that they
believed this to be Pharaoh the prophet
Muhammad wrote the opposite that he
wrote King okay like I said he could
have copied this not necessarily from
the but from from people um sort of
correcting this mistake or from
different manuscripts I'm not sure from
where well the thing is you're from
there you're just asserting I just told
you where he could have got it from from
other other Christians with various
different manuscripts I don't no but no
but all the manuscript say is Pharaoh
there's no manuscript that says it's
King yeah that we have so I you know
what can I say to that there's nothing
you can say to it what I'm saying is
admit that the Quran didn't copy the
Bible number two you cannot answer the
fact that how did the prophet Muhammad
know this fact you still can't answer it
and this is one I can give you plenty
I'll give you plent I'll give you
another one I'll give you another one
just in case I'll give you another one
yeah for example we go to the chapter of
uh Rome chapter of is called Rome yeah
now this is very interesting cuz the
Quran says that the Romans have been
defeated in the nearer land and after
their defeat they will come and win over
the Persians so do you know the Persian
Empire and the Roman Empire were at war
with each other yeah at the time yeah at
the time good okay so how long how long
were they at War for quite a bit they
were going back and forth there was
going there was times when Persians were
winning the Romans so what's this
impressive prophecy you will find out in
a minute yeah it's very impressive
actually it's actually I believe this is
a knockout blow yeah for anybody number
one the Persians have defeated the
Romans now in that time who would you
put your bets on if you've seen the
Persians have annihilated Romans Edward
Gibbons who's not a Muslim who's a
historian on the Roman Empire he says
that the way that the Romans were
defeated them coming back was an
impossible ability cuz I think hercus
was he was captured it was that the Rome
was on the way out Persia has defe and
took over many lands now who would you
put your bets on so whoever won at the
time first of need to understand that it
was a longgo battle yes okay if two
people are fighting in a UFC and I say
one guy's looking quite beat down and I
say hey I want to put my money on that
guy what's impressive about that cuz
that's what we profited and I don't find
anything impressive that so it's not the
knockout low that you think it is say
that again
please sorry I miss so in a UFC fight if
two people are fighting one guy's
getting punched down they've been
fighting for a long time and then I put
my money on the guy standing up by the
guys on the floor yeah what's impressive
about that okay good that's perfect
because the Quran does the opposite
would you put your money on the one
that's been on the floor so they would
have had they would have had wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait you said what's
impressive about the one who's being
beat down okay no who won who no no who
W no who won you said something very
clear if you are genuine you are about
to accept this because the Quran says
the opposite it he says the one that's
being beat down is going to come back
and win the war so it says so wait wait
wait wait it says the Romans have been
defeated it's saying that the Romans
have been defeated Edward Edward given
says the same thing now the Quran is
saying the Romans are going to come back
and win the war so now ask you a simple
question you just said something which
if you are genuine would you stand by it
the one that's on the floor is going to
come back and be you said I want not put
money on him the
Quran says the Romans will come and
defeat him and guess what the Romans
came back in 3 to 9 or 3 to S years and
beat the Persians okay so how did wa wa
wait how did the prophet Muhammad peace
upon him know this fact okay so he would
have made an analysis of the war and the
ongoing conflict and he would have put
his bets on that no nothing about you
look look look look you're just look do
you not understand you're being who did
I say that was I didn't say if it's
thank you my friend something you're a
disingenous person you are a full-blown
you're a Christian you're a disingenous
person you're not even agnostic let me
tell you something you're telling me
when I speak about scripture I have to
be careful is it why you so careful if
you're not a Christian if you're an
agnostic number one and number two and
number two no no no no number two listen
listen you but when it comes to the
Quran you you're not very careful you
speak however you like now let me tell
you something my friend you said very
clearly it is not impressive that the
one who's being beat for me to put the
money on I said you're right but the
Quran says the other the Quran says the
Romans will come back and defeat the
Persians and they were defeated so how
is that not impressive so the issue is
that impressive or not is that
impressive or not let respond yes is he
impressive or not so there's nothing
impressive about that they made a
historical analysis of the ongoing conf
and he saw who was going to win you're a
funny guy what's impress this is a
knockout blow you're funny guy you're a
funny guy oh my goodness that's
embarrassing you got intellectually
knocked out bro you got you got
humiliated
how I'm H and I'm only treating you like
this the only way I'm treating you like
this is because you are disingenuous you
just proven you know why when you said
oh how's he impressive if the guy on top
and I prove to you it's actually the one
on the floor the quran's predicted so
let me tell you did I did I specify the
listen to me look you're you're a
Christian don't come and say to me
you're not a Christian you're a
Christian and you are here lying
pretending that oh I'm just come in to
learn you're not you you are someone
that's hostile you're hostile H you're
misrepresenting it's your Jan I did J
pray over you your funeral was happening
you buried your so you want to insult
see you later my friend I'm insulting
you man I'm I intellectually destroyed
you bye-bye I don't want to talk to you
you're byebye byebye see you later bye
byee yeah yeah okay we'll see you by
byebye byebye bye you knocked yourself
out you know you know Tyson Fury he
knocked himself out yeah byebye see you
later yeah yeah yeah and the people com
to Islam alhamdulillah to Islam take
care look after yourself here take care
bye bye byebye don't touch me
move Islam net is establishing a Masjid
and a community center if you donate to
build this Masjid Allah will insh build
a house for you in Jenna with bricks of
gold and silver every person who prays
in this Masid every child that memorizes
the Quran you will in share in that
reward donate now guys and do not delay
[Music]